tonight we have extremely graphic new
video that reveals the very real horrors
of human trafficking and it's happening
every single day at our southern border
this is a true nightmare that the biden
administration is doing nothing to
resolve real lives being destroyed
senator cruz will be here with us he
will show us this video we'll respond to
that plus a bombshell new claim from a
government whistleblower oh i thought
the democrats love whistleblowers
detailing how a few high-ranking federal
officials now attempted to cover up and
downplay possible crimes committed by
the president's son hunter biden we have
that full report tonight and also
tonight a major announcement from the
vice president take a look here's a
tease
a woman sitting at the table wearing a
blue suit
we're going to play the full
cringe-worthy remarks that's coming up
but first we begin with what top
economists are calling a perfect storm
and it's one for you of pain and
suffering today the consumer confidence
index declined for the third straight
month the drop was even larger than
expected driving these numbers 91
million of your fellow americans adults
who are now unable to afford everyday
household expenses because of joe
biden's inflation and his energy
policies all told 40 percent of
americans are now having difficulty just
paying their bills now this includes
half of all senior citizens they cannot
afford essential expenses meanwhile
foreclosures they're on the rise new
home sales they have dropped to a 24
month low motor vehicles well the repo
man is back to being repossessed at an
alarming rate and in the peak of summer
this is sad for kids i used to love when
the ice cream truck came by mr softy uh
let's see good humor even ice cream
trucks are now being forced off the
streets they can't afford the insane
price of diesel to run their truck
even retail giant walmart just warned
investors that profits they're drying up
and a slowdown is imminent we're in the
middle of it sadly it's only going to
get worse from here buckle up the fed is
expected to announce another major rate
hike that should take place tomorrow we
expect seven five basis points in other
words three quarters of a full point
interest rate increase maybe a full
basis point and on thursday the second
quarter gdp two days from now
it's going to reveal whether or not
officially the u.s is in a recession the
atlanta fed they are predicting a
contraction in the second quarter of 1.6
percent now keep in mind this is
important it shouldn't be important but
it is important only because of the
biden administration lying the historic
barometer for or definition of a
recession is two straight quarters of
negative growth last quarter the u.s
recorded 1.6 percent minus 1.6 percent
growth negative growth this quarter the
economy also expected to be in the red
now instead of correct
making a course correction facing the
truth facing reality that we're in a
recession and focusing on changing
failed policies to revive our economy
lift this burden of inflation at a
41-year high the record high gas prices
we're paying the biden administration
they're more interested in parsing words
and playing word games now for two weeks
the white house has been trying to
rewrite the official definition of a
recession into something very obscure
and nebulous and simply if you're
charitable you say they're spinning you
if you're a realist like i am you'll say
they're outright lying to us and then to
make matters worse they are now vowing
that the u.s is definitely not headed
towards a recession joe biden said this
week god willing whatever that means now
today our very own peter ducey was on
his a game asking biden's very nervous
looking economic adviser about this very
shady approach to redefine what is a
well standard definition of a recession
i can't believe is it a recession are
you can you define what a woman is these
are the questions society's asking now
every day take a look
the president's economic advisors were
telling us
last year that inflation was going to be
temporary
that's not true
now the president's economic advisors
are saying there's not going to be a
recession
are you sure
well let me just say this
we
look at
a range of data we assess that data and
we
lay it out for ourselves and for the
president
but you don't have to take uh our our
our word uh on this
you know what i'll stick with that part
we won't take your word on this or
pretty much anything else
after the inflation is mere transitory
after that lie after joe biden announced
in december oh we've now reached the
peak of inflation that was seven percent
it's now what 9.1 the consumer price
index uh why would we trust anything
that they're saying here's the cold hard
truth the administration won't tell you
but you and your families need to know
so you can prepare for where we are we
are in a time of stagflation barreling
towards a full-blown recession it will
probably be deep there will not be well
any type of soft landing as they call it
americans are now struggling to pay
their bills fill up their gas tanks and
even put food on the table inflation is
at a 41-year high the biden
administration is doing nothing to
produce more energy oil gas coal
reopened refineries or curtail
government spending nearly every single
thing that caused inflation to spike in
the first place is now still in place
now the administration can call this
economic suffering pretty much whatever
they want but it won't change the dire
reality as one top economist told
bloomberg any prediction of a shallow
downturn is totally delusional take a
look
well now the consensus view is becoming
that
hard landing is likely as opposed to a
soft landing but now people say well be
short shallow mild plain vanilla you
know garden variety i beg to disagree i
think the many reasons why we're going
to have a severe recession and a severe
death and financial crisis so the idea
is going to be short and shallow it's
totally delusional
by the way roubini predicted the
collapse in 08 unfortunately
the biden white house they're totally
delusional right now according to them
the environment has been saved because
we're now importing oil from what russia
iran saudi arabia venezuela opec instead
of producing it right here at home
according to them trillions and
trillions of dollars in new spending and
printing had nothing to do with
inflation according to biden well he
created a record number of jobs when in
reality we have yet to fully recover
all the lost jobs from the covet
shutdown even biden's you know uh
persona as middle class joe is
completely delusional because under
biden's radical climate cult inspired
agenda poor middle class people on fixed
incomes especially those on fixed
incomes they are getting squeezed the
most they are suffering under these
policies these economic policies these
energy policies they're the ones that
are struggling to buy the gas they're
the ones having a hard time buying food
never mind food that they like they've
already made that adjustment and now
biden's only solution i got let him eat
cake buy an electric vehicle at 65 grand
where are you going to get the 65 grand
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else